if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
big massive dump you turn the faucet on
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water
rushes out to sea because people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times
as opposed to once dumps
dumps
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody a massive
dumps cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
big
[Music]
[Applause]
for the land
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now we can whimper we can whine
or we can fight we'll fight we'll fight
to fight fight
fighting fight fighting hard fight
fighting fight
[Music]
fighting
[Music]
and then there's the fight
[Music]
we're going to fight we're going to
fight
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we actually
have a variety of different
elements of good news to talk about
today where are my graphics by the way
i'm i'm surrounded by black boxes
what is going on here it's odd
can we fix that ah there we go there
they're coming back in i don't know why
it just took a moment
my graphics are here i felt like i was
in the void there for a second
um we have covered relief
passed now by the house and senate it
will go to joe biden
people will be getting cash soon with
which to buy david pakman show
memberships and there is
nothing nothing more excited than that
more exciting than that i'm almost
drooling on myself i'm so excited about
that
let's go to the moment just moments ago
the house is still going
and we'll listen in on what's going on
momentarily
but uh the bill was passed just moments
ago let's make sure we have audio
let's make sure we have video we want
everything
this was the big moment here we go
on this vote the a's are 220
the nays are 211.
the motion is adopted
[Applause]
and there it is nancy pelosi speaker of
the house
[Applause]
yes with a very strong announcement that
it indeed has been passed here is our
friend eric swalwell let's
listen to him let's talk about some
other rights
in this country like the right
to pray in church the right to dance at
a party the right
to come home from a concert the right to
come back
home safely and alive those are rights
that matter to
and i am for this because i think about
a mother who told me
a couple years ago to keep fighting on
this issue because every day when she
puts her children
in the car and sends them off to school
before they get out of the car she
closes her eyes
right so he's doing stories but that's
fine they have passed covet relief
and money is going to start getting to
people now the vote is over for
everybody joining us the vote is over
coveted relief has been passed and it is
a great thing
things are really looking up at the top
of the hour
we will have an announcement from joseph
r
biden jr the pr oh god jim jordan hold
on gentlemen is recognized
thank you mr speaker he's just uh he's
just doling out time we will have an
announcement expected
moments from now from joe biden
that he has secured wait for it
100 million
additional johnson and johnson
coronavirus vaccines now let me do the
math 100 million doses
one dose per person let me figure this
out
one divided by one is one zero
zero zero zero zero okay that is enough
for 100
million people 100 million doses for 100
million people
um we may not even need these in the end
and
my my instinct is actually that these
jnj
additional doses are more of a backstop
in case there's a supply issue
with pfizer or moderna
and we will likely end up giving these
vaccines to other countries
that need them every country should have
vaccine access
so we are going to hear that
announcement at the top of the hour from
joe biden
so think about what we have going on
today and listen there is
tragedy happening in this country we
still have
you know 1500 people a day dying
just in the u.s from the virus we have
people on unemployment
struggling to pay uh for food and
housing
it's not like everything's great now but
we have coveted relief passed
today people will start getting money
soon joe biden about to announce 100
million additional vaccine doses
the stock market is not the economy
but another incredible day
for the dow uh bitcoin
is going bonkers um i mean
just a lot of things are starting to
come together
and it doesn't mean there aren't
problems to fix and all of this
different stuff but a lot is happening
that is going in the right direction
you look at covered cases
those are continuing to decline and they
need to continue declining further
you look at covet deaths and they are
declining increasingly quickly
acceleration down
down more than 55 percent at this point
still tragic
but we've got to keep it going uh
vaccinations
continue we are now up to 2.15 million
doses per day
biden promised a million we're at two
we're going to three i think so a lot of
things going in the right direction
and that is a that's a really good thing
i mean how can anyone say it's bad
but we have to continue doing more okay
ferret queen coming in with the first
super chat of the day
a heroic and principled super chat
asking does it extend unemployment
benefits set to end this month
yes it does the bill passed today
includes enhanced unemployment
and uh through i believe september
i don't have there's been so many
versions of the bill i don't have it in
front of me
but it does extend unemployment so that
is all
good it is all good let me thank some
great people
i want to say thanks to tristan
who just subscribed via twitch six
months thank you
also want to say thanks to helen dear
for the subscription
madd 1230 caspa
as well as tiny aim
and stacy nichols that's six
emo vulcan number seven
uh zero plus seven is seven
putting us at seven for the day
and of course i am going to be doing
hyperbolic and histrionic
praise of anybody who gets a membership
on my website
at joinpackman.com so
a lot of a lot of good things happening
today
something absolutely horrifying marjorie
taylor green this is recently uncovered
video from cpac
she did a side panel at cpac a couple of
weeks ago
here she is referring to foreign
countries like guam
guam is an american territory um
people people in guam are american
citizens here is marjorie taylor green
take a listen to this
a regular person and i wanted to take my
regular person
normal everyday american values she's
completely
normal guys remember that which is we
love our country
we believe our hard-earned tax dollars
should just go for
america not for what
china russia the middle
no money for the foreign country of guam
what country is that oh it's the united
states oh the people of guam are
american citizens
oh no oh no so
um you know this is what we call
weaponized ignorance
complete complete uh weaponized
weaponized ignorance
very sad so there's marjorie taylor
green
here's tucker carlson basically saying
listening to doctors is gay
i know i mean it's it it's not it's not
the way i talk about things
but here is tucker saying that a chinese
guy
says taking precautions is effeminate
which is code for gay
and then tucker's saying that also
applies to listening to dr fauci
uh this is the level of discourse
this is the level of discourse let's
take a listen here is uh
here is tucker
well this tells you everything in march
of last year the leadership of the
united states and of china
both declared national emergencies in
the u.s tony fauci warned congress that
reopening american businesses could
cause coronavirus outbreaks the
government may not be able to control
going outside tony fauci said was just
too risky
by the way that's a lie dr fauci never
said don't go outside
meanwhile in china where the chronovirus
originated a top advisor to the chinese
government declared that the country was
experiencing a very different kind of
threat a more profound threat
the problem he said was a national
masculinity crisis
chinese boys quote have been spoiled by
housewives and female teachers
and they were becoming as a result quote
delicate timid and effeminate
a feminist since they were becoming
people who might listen to someone like
tony fauci
[Laughter]
people who might listen to tony fauci
are
delicate timid and
effeminate this is educated right wing
code
for listening to doctors is gay
that's what tucker is saying now by the
way i want to be really clear and i made
this point on today's podcast and you'll
see the clip later
um i don't care what tucker carlson
looks like
i don't care what tucker carlson sounds
like i don't care what tucker carlson
wears
but is tucker carlson the epitome of
republican masculinity
uh you know country club bow tie wearing
high pitched voice guy
now is is this the the image
of right wing masculinity like who is he
to even be saying stuff about listening
to doctors is effeminate
uh and again i don't care it's the
hypocrisy of tucker
taking taking this approach just
ridiculous that this is the level of
discourse where we are now
uh operating truly truly uh stunning
stuff okay
sinful solutions sends a super chat and
says no message
people asking where are the super chats
the super chats will appear over there
but only they only start appearing with
the third one and we only have two so
far that's why you're not seeing super
chats over there but they're working
fine and you will see them soon
i want to say thanks to candies poppin
for signing up via twitch astrolycos has
gifted five subs
five plus one is six snowflake warrior
is number seven
okay seven and seven plus seven is
fourteen
let's listen to lauren bobo bobert
jordan
i was raised mr speaker in a democrat
home
democrat i understand how these policies
are deceiving right i understand that
we're told
guns are scary stuff we're and that's
what we believed
because we trusted the people that we
voted for
but just as most things in life i grew
up quite away with words really william
f buckley reincarnated huh
is ignorant to firearms and the proper
use
of them when i became a business owner
i'm get honestly i'm getting columbine
vibes from her and that's not a joke i'm
not making fun of anything
restaurant where a man was physically
beat to death there were no weapons
involved he was beat
to death by another man's hand is it
beat or beaten
he was beat to death i don't even know
that that makes sense
i'm five foot tall oh god i barely weigh
a hundred pounds i
need something against a stronger
potential aggressor to defend myself
with
talk about women's rights don't take my
right away
to protect myself i mean seriously what
are we doing here
i asked the supporters she's still going
about wanting to bring guns onto the
house floor
disarm americans and leave them
vulnerable without help you want to
defund
our police and yet leave us without a
way
to protect ourselves our founding
fathers gave us a list of items
and said don't touch these things and
i'm telling you general ladies time has
expired
keep your hands off general later's time
has expired members are
reminded to address their comments to
the chair the gentleman from
new york is recognized mr speaker i now
yield one minute
to this all right so there's floor
speeches but the big
if you're just joining us the
coronavirus stimulus was passed
39 minutes ago take a listen on this
vote the a's
are 220 the nays are 211.
the motion is adopted
so covet stimulus pass now needs only to
be signed into law by joe biden
he will do so very soon and we are about
to hear from joe biden about
100 million
additional vaccine doses so a lot of
good
things happening today a few other super
chats derek leland says get your fouchy
ouchie everyone
well said bryce roberts says as a
bisexual man
tucker offense yet again
and chakuseki says the man at the
restaurant had a very nice
salad and was beat to death golden beets
can be deadly
i love golden beets i really do i
consider the beet almost a perfect
vegetable almost a perfect vegetable
alex van der pol says we need to
ridicule jared golden for his no vote on
the relief bill
i want to say a huge thank you
to really a national hero if i were
president
i would be giving ellis bailey the
presidential medal of freedom ellis
not only just grabbed a membership at
joinedpakman.com becoming number 15
today
ellis used the coupon code better21
absolutely no trouble using it the
coupon code working beautifully
functioning perfectly absolutely
perfectly
a true patriot ellis bailey
signing up at joinpackman.com also
thanks to blue moon
maiden and melting face for signing up
via twitch
number 16 and 17 today
thanks very much guys uh standing by for
joe biden
a few other things to go over let's see
we already did that
oh i didn't cover today's white house
press briefing but i was told that peter
duchy
had another one of these kind of black
hole
weird questions for jen saki let's take
a listen to what he said
bbc tells these shelter facilities
okay so it's still on border they can be
at full capacity
if they are careful about cobit many of
them do
but when the cdc tells schools that they
can open
in person at full capacity many of them
don't
is there a school in particular that you
have as an example that didn't
do that are most schools in this country
at full capacity with
in-person learning no i don't know if
that's supposed to be rhetorical uh
no are there a specific school though
that is not following the cdc guidelines
of
of implementing the mitigation steps so
they can reopen
the cdc is saying schools you can be at
every school can be at full capacity
what this is the cdc
guideline the cdc guidelines just to be
clear because i think this is very
important to be very clear and specific
on
they they gave eight mitigation steps
that schools can take
it's like what's even the question quite
frankly
safely reopen a number of schools have
actually recently reopened
schools in washington dc some have
schools in many districts across the
country
but each school district needs to make
the decision about whether they
are able to take those mitigation steps
the president has also been clear
some of these school districts need
additional funding there's 160 billion
dollars
in this package that he's going to sign
into law later this week this guy's such
a lightweight isn't he
secretary of education will be quite
focused on working with school districts
to
help them reopen but more school
districts are reopening
more kids are in classrooms every single
day but since they are not
all back from an administration position
or from your perspective
have the border patrol unions and the
hhs unions been easier to work with
than the teachers unions what a
dumb question what is he he
he's he's like feeling around in the
dark for something
i i think that's a little bit of mixing
different circumstances
exactly i would say that it's children
all in
tight quarters uh i mean a classroom but
not quite funny not quite i would say
it's not when you go to it's not funny
it's because you're losing the actual
substance
that let's let's take a responsible
approach to the two issues okay too late
for that
school's reopening there's been eight
mitigation steps that have been
announced by the cdc to implement right
yeah
every school district is going to work
to implement those on a timeline that is
you know the the where i would have
jen's doing a good job here of dealing
with a guy who is a complete and total
lightweight but the approach i might
take is
you know peter i really appreciate what
you're pointing out
which is that we have situations with
kids crowded together you're right
there's a similarity kids crowded
together at the border versus kids
crowded together in schools
the difference is that in schools
we have a completely different
relationship to these kids
they're our parents these aren't
unaccompanied minors we have remote
learning so
with the kids in school we have the
privilege of being able to say
this is how we should open we have a
list of steps
and we're going through those steps with
the kids at the border
the kids are here and we we have to
figure out what to do we can't say
hey let's do remote border crossings
from your computers for the next few
weeks
it's not analogous in any way beyond the
fact that we're dealing with kids
anyway you guys get it you guys get it
um okay
i want to say thanks to bob villain as
well as kaladin
for signing up via twitch your numbers
18 and 19.
i also want to say thank you to lauren
beaubert's pistol
lauren beaubert's pistol has just signed
up for a membership at joinedpakman.com
uh if i had a kid i would make you my
kids uh
godparent that is such a nice thing for
you to do to sign up at
uh joinpackman.com very much appreciate
it
other super chats coming in dalton says
david what's the deal with trump and now
all republicans using democrat instead
of democratic yeah they've been doing
that for a while it's just a pejorative
they've come up with that's all
nh barracks is calling for a pacman only
fans
nebia shower promotion yikes
we'd need a few more members for that
bay photo letting us know that merrick
garland has been confirmed
70 30. good news
jesse miner says my mom was robbed at
knifepoint on her way home last night
walmart we need deep systemic financial
reform
to curb desperation not guns i'm so
sorry to hear that jesse that sounds
horrible
i hope your mom is okay giovanni says
the 3600 child tax credit is per child
right
it's per child but 3 600 i bel correct
me if i'm wrong people in the chat
3 600 is for really young kids i believe
the
the credit is less as kids are older
can you can people fact check me on that
that's what i remember from the last
yeah 3 600 is for the youngest kids
maybe even under
five younger than five yep or zero to
six
somewhere in that range
yeah okay good very good
all right so we've gotten that sorted
out which i very much appreciate
uh let's see do i have any unban
requests no
people lately who have been banned seem
to know that they deserve to be banned
they haven't been appealing their bans
at this point in time so we've got
that do i have any new songs i do have a
couple let me see so these are still
most of the new songs i'm getting lately
are still relayed they're plays off of
this voicemail which came in
i guess it was about a couple weeks ago
related to this one
to this one i'll tell you one thing boy
trump is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
you are bought and paid for
okay so that guy most of the new songs
are related to that for example
this song from dm squared i like this
one
is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
i'll tell you one thing boy trump
has got more money than you'll ever have
yeah oh i'm realizing i don't think i've
played this one before
this is actually so this is new okay
yeah good and
paid
trump is more man than you'll ever be
so that's the dm squared song and then i
have one this one i have played this is
vape error this is also a really good
one
trump is more man than you'll ever be
i'll tell you one thing
[Music]
i could see this like you know you go to
a club in like valencia spain
and it's 3am and this is playing
[Music]
okay all right good so anyway those are
those are the new songs i have for you
guys
for the time being um
what else i think that's basically it i
think i'm basically caught up
ceo at crystalsoft says david should the
u.s consider letting texas go
since they demand federal money but
won't take care of their own systems
well
it's not clear texas wants to go i know
there's a secession movement i don't
think it's
i don't think it's super popular in
texas i want to say
thank you to cindy conroy for signing up
at joinpackman.com
cindy i absolutely love it thank you
so much for the support you are my
honorary grandmother today
and you may be very young i'm just
saying i i remember my
my grandmother's very kindly so it's a
it's a compliment
it's a compliment you might be 20 years
old and that's fine
um it's just a term of endearment also
thank you to
crystalina for subscribing via twitch
with the message
getting my vaccine right now
congratulations crystalina that's great
also thanks to huckabili82 for
subscribing with twitch prime
thanks to nug wrangler
for gifting a subscription to annadyne
quinine and also thanks to games
gamer princess that is for twenty one
plus
four it's like a hundred right
no it's twenty five very nice appreciate
that
um do i have any voicemails i don't
think i do
let's just take a look let's check both
sources of voicemails as we wait for joe
biden here
voicemails let's see what we've got
we might we may have as of this morning
i didn't have anything but they they
just come in all day
nothing on the main number let's see if
we have anything from jimmy
oh we do jimmy from philly continues
calling the old number
he called yesterday let's take a listen
i have to be ready to cut it but
david jimmy from zoey white
so we had a democrat
in the white house less than a month and
cobit is going away
shocking jimmy from zoey white
so we had a democrat
in the white house less than a month and
covert is going away caleb
how many o's and u's are in that
c-o-u-o-u-o-u-u-o-o-u-i-d
it's a long word so that's jimmy from
philly
and then we had one from last week
although this might not be new let me
see here
david jimmy from philly white so i don't
want an experimental on trial
poison injected to me oh it's anti-vaxx
jimmy this is new
meaning he doesn't come comes
her immunity comes from exposure
experience
wow he is off the rails here's another
david jimmy from philly so i'm watching
this thing you're doing about any
baxters and
you claim to have all these emails from
people and uh i don't i don't claim i
have emails from people i've shown them
you picked the one dumb ass that got it
wrong right right
wow you you hit the little hanging proof
right david
how academic of you right i should have
picked the more uh
trustworthy unhinged anti-vaxxer emails
to show you
anyway at some point she says to you
um you're not responding to me because
this is the truth well david you're not
responding to me
because i promised your ass on our last
phone call
what is jimmy even talking about i'm
trying to
actually i don't even remember our last
phone call let's see if i can even find
it
uh let's see pacman
jimmy from jimmy from
philly something's wrong with my space
bar can you ima
my space bar i think just went down what
the heck
oh no it's only not working in youtube
search that's weird
pacman jimmy from
philly i i that is bizarre
oh it's a youtube search bug oh
interesting
that's interesting yeah i've never i
just lost my space bar
uh let me do the search in the youtube
back end and see if i can find it
description jimmy
philly apply
um the last call with jimmy
oh you know what it might have been on a
live stream because the last call that
we uploaded independently was
august 1st which i can't imagine is what
jimmy's actually referring to let's just
see
oh and this is even a voicemail yeah i
don't even know i'm not even going to
bother
i i can't it must be part of a live
stream but i don't even know where where
that was
i want to say a huge thank you to melvi
avalon
melvie just signed up at joinpakman.com
using the coupon code better21 the code
was perfectly spelled
and extraordinarily well executed melvi
thank you so much for your support i
love it
that you signed up on my website also i
want to say thanks to kino hermes
for six months on twitch boy meets many
for nine months
on twitch juvenesco for four months
some champagne for signing up
beau flex man is now at 13 months
mad max at three
and that is six additional people
putting us at 32. thanks yeah
we actually i think right now we started
in august
of uh 2019 on twitch
august september october november
december that's five and then 12 is 17
18 19. i think we're starting to see
maybe some 19 month subs
and maybe some maybe some 20s i'm not
exactly sure but we're getting into the
1920
sort of range um i
do have a um
unban request to adjudicate
let me grab my gavel here it is
we are convening this as a court of
impeach i'm sorry not of impeachment as
a court of unbanned requests
this is a user whose username is merely
numbers
let's see what got them banned they were
banned
today 12 minutes ago they've already
appealed
let's see they showed up today
okay here are the here are their
messages
i talk boy still to i love me madar one
for planet
i make hotel strim still too i talk
bitcos mesno
america present kosovo i talk does no
present america want you mess politique
for kosovo after problem
is this a different language or is this
nonsense i can't actually tell does
anybody recognize this language
what is italk
okay then they show people already want
and unban just because it's funny
then what got them banned today is they
showed up and 12
16 minutes ago they said hey david what
you disment twitch problem for manny bit
cause this iggy bang i talked this men
should go
that was held for hostility i can't even
make heads or tails out of it
i can't even tell if it's hostile that's
the funny thing i don't know what
they're talking about
uh the auto mod seems to seems to
understand it
and then they sent another one of these
nonsense messages
they were banned by our friend greenman
oh my god and then the unbanned request
is why you me block
i boss
does is this is this making fun of some
language
that i don't recognize or is this
another language
and we are aren't understanding like
what's going on
people like it
it can't be a bot what does it mean that
it's a bot
is it albanian no i don't think so
i don't know i'm really i could this is
this is maybe the toughest one because
it's like there is something funny about
it
but these comments really have no place
somehow the bot
recognized it as hostile which i find
hilarious
i don't know what to do about this one
i'll put it to a vote i think just
because i can't even tell what it is
let's do a straw poll and it will be
should
i unban
gibberish user
unban permaban
um create poll
all right i'm gonna paste this for a few
times in twitch
and then i'll do it a few times on
youtube i really don't know what to do
this one is genuinely tough let's see
what people want me to do i will go by
uh
i will i won't vote i'll just look at
the results
you guys tell me i i really this is the
toughest decision that i
as a judge have had to make um
and i'm guessing it'll just be a moment
until some of the votes start towing in
the meantime
let me um read some super chats tranquil
rabies wants to know will republicans
voting no on stimulus matter or will
voters care more about owning the libs
sadly i think the latter i think the
latter dndn family says live in texas
had my first run-in with an
anti-massacre touting but abbott said we
don't have to anymore after refusing to
comply with store policy
right stores can still have a policy uh
could that be real
233 unbanned votes 100 to zero there's
no way in hell that that's the case
i'm gonna give it a moment it'll
probably resolve on its own
have you really been far even as decided
to use
even go want to do look more like you
know what daniel that's exactly right in
fact i find that message hostile
there it is okay so now we have a more
accurate
sense of what's going on looks like by
about a two to one margin people want
an unban we'll give it a moment more
hey david saw your video on stoicism do
you see yourself making future content
geared towards
philosophic schools of thought sorry
about your space bar yeah i would do
more philosophy content for sure
david not only the 3600 tax credit but
if you spend 8 000 you get half
back whatever you spend for extra kid
credit
that i don't know about that's not
making a lot of sense to me
forecast on health care legislation over
next four years we'll do that probably
next week
all right clearly this is an unban so i
am officially adjudicating this
as an unban for this user i mean if they
come back and do more stuff they'll
probably find themselves banned again
but i don't know people wanted an unban
so i'm doing i'm doing an unban it's
fine
all right let's check in briefly as to
what's happening in the house
children to be safe but eight
years after sandy hook
and three years after the shooting at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
my district
we should be ashamed that we have waited
so long
and wasted so much time when we could be
saving lives
we cannot have safe communities until we
fix the crumbling foundation of our gun
laws
that is the background check system
universal background checks will help
keep guns
out of dangerous hands they will save
lives in our schools
they will save lives it seems like just
opportunism right now
given that a lot of people are tuned in
because of the vote to pass covet
stimulus
a variety of different um speeches
happening here but we are standing by
for joe biden's big
big announcement big big announcement on
the jnj merck partnership which is going
to be
absolutely huge huge huge huge
i want to say thanks to fastn for
subscribing via twitch with the message
thanks for the chirpy streams unbanned
the bots
lurdon has also subscribed for three
months combo carl for eight
that is three 32 plus three is
35. i feel very strongly about that
stephen says via super chat the
republicans have shifted from being
against
deficit to stopping deficit due to their
cancel culture
issues they have negated any
responsibility regarding economic issues
democrats pass 15
minimum wage okay sam says why is biden
waiting to sign the relief bill
i don't know that he is it just passed
about an hour ago
i i don't i'm not aware of biden waiting
ryan says there was a massive dump in
unbanned votes
there was do you think mccarthy is
endorsing marjorie taylor green's antics
for a jor
adjourning every morning he's been
silent on it who's in control
is it him or anyone oh yeah i actually
have video of that let me see if it's
here
um yeah here's marjorie taylor green
randomly demanding that the house
adjourn and then demanding a roll call
vote
without objection the general woman from
georgia is recognized for one minute
i thank my colleague and the good
gentleman here for explaining
why 1.9 trillion in spending
is reckless irresponsible and the wrong
thing to do
we still have one trillion dollars set
aside
for coveted relief and spending there is
no need to enslave the american people
she disgusts me in a deep and visceral
way
children our grandchildren our great
grandchildren
and generations going forward in more
debt we are at 28 trillion dollars
in debt by the way i'm actually i'm very
interested in
various american accents is turning
every vowel into an
eye a georgia accent thing because i
don't know that i'm familiar with that
like generation becomes generation
every everything is an everything
becomes an i this congress
is ramming through unbelievable things
at a rapid pace
this must be stopped we have to give
pause in consideration to what we're
doing
this is a waste of money and a complete
waste of time reopening
america is a much better way to go mr
speaker i ask for a motion to adjourn
the question is on the motion those in
favor say aye
those in favor say no the no's have it
mr speaker asked for a roll call vote
what a waste of time
fiscal conservatism asking for a roll
call vote on an
obvious no just pathetic i mean really
really pathetic
i want to say thanks to alex van der pol
who just signed up
perfectly on joinpakman.com alec you are
new member number 36 today alec taking
advantage of the coupon code better21
typing it perfectly the website
welcomed it accepted the code and had no
issue whatsoever granting the discount
also want to say thank you to um
oh no that's it sorry okay other super
chats coming in
bam chaley says dave why are biden's
dogs
allowed to crowd the secret service but
schools can't reopen
i mean this seems a little effeminate
now yeah that
i know that you're kidding that is
roughly the level on which
um the the press the right wing media is
operating right now
and uh we're very nicely done subtle
subtle but well done i like that
uh yeah bizarre absolutely bizarre stuff
okay um let's see here oh somebody's
asking to hear the old
jimmy from philly voicemail all right
let's listen to what it was this was
august of 202 david p you guys are gonna
love this
um i have this furious trumpist
jimmy from philly who calls him and
um he is very much like an auntie
i don't even remember this this is like
new for me uh
bernie sanders anti-left type guy he
doesn't like
handouts he wants people to pull
up by their bootstraps and all that
typical stuff
he heard that i was getting a new
microphone and indeed if you're watching
today today is the first day with my new
shure sm7b i know it doesn't sound
perfect yet but
we're we're working on it and so jimmy
called
and he said hey can i have your old
microphone for free take a listen to
this
david jimmy from philly i hear you're
getting a new microphone
right uh how about let me have the old
one
i'll pay shipping yeah so uh
jimmy wants free stuff what has jimmy
done to earn
my evre20 which i've used for
10 years if i'm going to get honestly
we've been thinking should we auction
off i've used that microphone for 10
years it still works perfectly right i
could sign the microphone with a sharpie
or yeah i mean if people don't want it
we could auction it off for example
and do something interesting i'm going
to send it
to a furious trumpist who i've had to
kick off of my phone lines
for his virulently homophobic statements
that's who i'm going to send a 500
microphone to nope so jimmy first of all
why not figure out
how to pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and get yourself a microphone
you don't have this wasn't a bad segment
actually
spent 500 bucks like on an evr e20 micro
you can get a 20
microphone okay jimmy so that's first of
all you don't have to come begging me
for handouts
right and number two if i'm going to
give the microphone to someone
not going to give it to someone who
calls in and says such disgusting things
you know i appreciate hearing from
people from all sides jimmy and
your calls are welcome but right a free
microphone
come on it seems like it's a little bit
of uh entitlement
that i'm hearing there so no okay so
that
that was the last voicemail from jimmy
from philly
although i don't know i'm guessing i
spoke to him on the phone
since then but maybe not i mean time has
been flying maybe i actually haven't had
him on the phone
since uh since august of 2020. i have no
idea
uh my instinct is i did my instinct is i
did
mark phillian says in canada the jnj
vaccine is already available first doses
will be available by the end of the
month
yeah there's also i mean people have
already been vaccinated with jnj
if you look now see the cdc is now
including jnj and its data people
receiving the single shot are counted as
those with at least one
dose and those fully vaccinated so we
already have had
those vaccinations start although i
don't
i don't know exactly what the number is
so far of administered
jnj let's see if it mentions here
how is each state performing
who's eligible
um oh let's see if the underlying cdc
data tells us how many jnjs
have been injected so we've got
delivered and administered
all right and people vaccinated by
age total doses
territories by vaccine ah
here it is so about half a million
jnjs have been injected
and about 3.6 million jnjs have been
delivered so there's the data
48 million out of 60 million kaisers
have been
injected 46 out of 63 million delivered
modernity doses have been injected
and only about half a million of the 3.6
million j j
johnson vaccines have been uh injected
so far
and then in terms of fully vaccinated
17 million have been fully vaccinated
with pfizer
15 million fully vaccinated with moderna
and then
because it's one dose basically the same
number of jnj
full vaccinations this is great data
excellent excellent data
um very good okay
we are standing by for joe biden for an
event with the ceos of johnson and
johnson and merck they are expected to
announce
um a hundred million additional doses of
the jnj vaccine
oh i see someone thanking me on twitch
for recommending the book the last
policeman
saying it's fantastic it is a really
great book um
the last policeman check this out i've
interviewed actually ben winters i
recently read this book it's a really
quick read
the last policeman by ben winters
here's the concept what's the point in
solving murders if we're all going to
die anyway
detective hank palace has faced this
question ever since an asteroid hovered
into view
there's no chance left no hope just six
precious months
until impact the last policeman presents
a fascinating portrait of a
pre-apocalyptic united states
the economy spirals downward while crops
rot in the fields
churches and synagogues are packed
people are walking off the job
but not hank palace he's investigating a
death by hanging in a city
that sees a dozen suicides every day
except this one feels suspicious
and palace is the only cop who cares
yeah it's good and it's part of a
trilogy
so i read this one a couple weeks ago
i have ordered the second one which is
countdown city and then there's the
third one world of trouble
really good and ben winters also wrote
the book underground airlines
which um came out i guess a couple of
years ago
and it's also really good christina says
david sorry if i missed the reason but
why was hatred
mail removed from your show oh okay this
is interesting yeah if
if peop i'll tell the story now and if
people want to clip this then maybe
we'll re-upload it
as a um we'll re-upload it as a clip
so basically because because of what
happened with the election
and the amount of violence real and
threatened that's been going on
as many of you know we get threats all
the time and they're forwarded to
authorities we've had
fbi agents have actually shown up at the
houses of people who have who have sent
threats um and there's many stories
i could tell maybe 20 years from now i
will tell them
the long and short of it is a bunch of
people including federal authorities
said that the hatred mail segment is
probably creating
sort of like false positives
and and making it hard creating more
noise around the signal
and they felt strongly that
um it's probably it probably should be
suspended because
situa trumpets are so violent and
so volatile and then january 6th
happened
so basically that's it we very quietly
just stopped doing hatred mail like i
didn't do an announcement the the
recommendation from
um security consultants and fbi
was probably probably cut it for the
time being things are just too volatile
um so uh that's that's the reason
that's the reason i don't know i need to
say unceremoniously yeah
and obviously i was in touch with um
hatred male
guy and you know maybe it'll come back
is he still getting paid it was a
volunteer thing you know the funniest
thing hatred mail guy is a professional
voiceover artist one of the funniest
things he would write to me
about hatred mail is i've done voice
over for
movies tv shows commercials this is him
speaking
the the only thing my wife thinks i do
that's cool is hatred mail hatred mail
guy's wife
is a big fan and she was uh loving
hatred mail
but that's the story that's the story
uh okay other super chats david are you
on goodreads
i haven't updated it for years i am on
there but i haven't updated it for years
i'm a truck driver and pass through
berlin new york kind of often and lately
have seen
f biden flags on homes scary stuff that
is scary
alex is getting my first dose on
saturday i'm on multiple
immunosuppressants so i'm excited here's
to hoping for little side effects yes
i was quite ill with the fever
uh after both doses but
almost no one else i know was most
people had not no symptoms at all
i want to say a big thank you to ivan
moreno who just signed up at
joinpacman.com
yusuf dabney is a new member
at joinpackman.com and
candace dearolf is a new member at
joinpakman.com
members 37 38 and 39
everybody using the coupon code better21
wait is that right is everybody using it
yes everybody using it also want to say
thanks to some people on twitch freddie
bob
has subscribed for four months voison
is a new twitch prime sub sad squash
and lung shanks have subscribed
that is four people putting us at 43.
thanks guys very much appreciate that
okay so that was a that was the question
about a book i thought there was one
other thing though
um
interesting but i lost it
hey david i really enjoyed the chess
tournament you put on last year any
chance for more this year
hey you guys want to hear something
interesting actually about what's going
on with chess
this is this could be cool many of you
might know
i call him a conservative commentator
i i i don't know if it's the right term
but i think it
sort of applies coleman hughes
and again you don't have to agree with
everything coleman says coleman hughes
plays chess and he's roughly at my same
level
he recently sent me a message saying do
you want to do some chess
on twitch just like a chess event it's
sort of like
sometimes you'll see a match between
people who know how to play chess and
they both stream it
i think the idea is a match between
coleman and i and we're both terrible
but i think it actually could be
interesting so we might line that up for
next week it'll be a totally different
thing maybe i'll do twitch only
i don't know if the youtube audience um
would like it as much now it's
conceivable that he has deliberately
been
playing below his level so that i think
he's not that good
and then he crushes me that's i could be
getting hosed here
it's totally possible but i think it's a
it's a cool idea so coleman hughes and i
may be doing
a low end uh
chess thing he may be smurfing
he may be smurfing yeah david what about
the standpoint of
memes i don't think i have anything from
the standpoint of memes let me just
double check
um do i have any memetic
content
no oh hold on this i i don't know what
this is but i want to see this this is
dave rubin's war on math
i met i meant to take a look at this
let's look at it together
how many pages here you've got uh oh it
doesn't even have page numbers it
doesn't even have page numbers so you
guys would like that you wokesters
because i know you guys don't like math
so there's no page numbers on this thing
how much is a yearly subscription to the
new york times let's find
out let's find out what it is i pay four
bucks a month for
new york times i don't know i'll try to
come up on the fly with some things that
would be a better
a better use of the money it's got to be
what couple hundred bucks
i think it's forty eight dollars yearly
subscription to the times
we're gonna work on that we'll get back
to that all right i'm gonna jump on to
the next story we're gonna work on that
one
um oh it's okay so it looks like it's 17
8 every four weeks for one year eight
dollars
uh oh it's getting complicated dollars
every four weeks
for one year give me the math on that
bust out some math for me who's got a
math
you got a you got one of them there are
calculators on that computer
it is eight dollars every four weeks for
one year so multiply that by 52 can you
do that
this is i don't know why this is so
funny
it sounds like it's got to be about 10
grand eight times 52
somebody help me here what's that 416.
it's about 400 bucks
is eight it's eight times 52 416 did i
do that right
it's about 400 bucks work with me yeah
about 400 bucks okay i got two math and
magicians over here okay
um the point is for 400 whoever you are
i'm sure you can find better things you
could buy a really
great bottle of like high-end tequila
that's really weird okay well struggling
with math
oh that's interesting yeah i actually so
someone just asked
what went on in my head um when i
calculated 8 times 52.
um the way i do it in my head is i'm
doing 8
times 50 which is 400 and 8 times 2 is
16
400 plus 16 is 416. that's the way i
break it down in my head
i'd be curious whether people do it
differently that's how most people are
doing it yeah
i know that that's liberal math yeah i
know i
break it down and that's how oh okay a
lot of people doing it that way
yeah i you know one of the things i
sometimes think about is i should get up
to speed on multiplying three-digit
numbers together i don't know if that's
something everybody can learn to do
i i i you know if i really sat here and
like
used all full brain power maybe i could
do like
124 times 366. i know some people who
can do that
really easily i would be interested in
learning that i think that there is some
some some trick to it uh
okay some algorithmic tool that could be
used
but it's like why bother right i have a
calculator for the sake of it i think it
builds character
thanks to kevin stetfield kevin just
signed up at
uh joinedpakman.com kevin
used the coupon code better21
and kevin is new member number 44 today
other super chats matthew nicodemus says
and this is why i don't have a sub yet
biden's been talking for minutes already
and you're on this nonsense
i mean the video's not live
um is there some other stream if biden's
talking then i don't know why the white
house stream isn't even live
i mean talk to the white house uh
let's see live
live now
who is live now let's see
house passes stimulus
jury selection house vote
oh look my own stream is showing up in
youtube's live feed that's interesting
um biden hosts an event that's the
stream that we're on
yeah i'm not i'm not seeing any other
stream that is live right now
oh that's just a troll okay
i mean it might be nice to have biden
vaccine live i'd like to have a backup
stream
let's see if we can find one
yahoo finance let's see
oh it looks like it's about to start it
hasn't started all right
man i got i guess i i i was tricked you
trolled me
wow you derailed the stream
congratulations
matthew your mother is a hamster
abrasive adam is concerned about the
legality of the coupon
code i i would be too i agree
what's going on here
hey david do you ever give small
creators feedback on their content
if so i'd love thoughts on the channel
trailer i put up you know i really don't
i really don't have time for that
um but maybe maybe at some point we'll
work something out
um this is me yusuf dabney i don't know
how to comment on the discord i'm new to
it how
uh you just get on the discord i'm not
sure i know what you're asking
maybe google how to sign up for a
discord server not a troll i was on pbs
news
your father smelt of elderberries sir
i don't know what that means i mean
biden hasn't spoken yet right like we're
watching it now
it's running 40 minutes late which is
bizarre
oh sorry now people are mad because i'm
not thanking twitch
thanks to victoria for the twitch prime
sub
thanks to freddie bob oh wait no i
already thanked freddy bob oh it's just
victoria
all right thank you victoria i
appreciate that that's 45.
almost at 46. and here is
joe biden and other people
let's listen to what's going on we'll
mute this one
good afternoon everyone i really
couldn't be more honored to be here
celebrating this landmark collaboration
today between johnson and johnson merck
and the biden administration to further
accelerate production
of our one shot jansen johnson johnson
kova 19 vaccine
i want to give a big thanks to president
biden for having us here today
and for his leadership effort to johnson
and johnson's
135 000 employees and our global
partners
for the really exceptional effort and
expertise that have gone in
to making sure our covet 19 vaccine
reaches as many
corners of the world as quickly as
possible
and also to my good friend ken frazier
and to merck for their partnership and
for his personal friendship over the
years you know our industry
it's realized in the early days of the
pandemic the vaccine development
it wasn't a race against each other's as
competitors
it's really a race against time to
defeat a common
enemy right today we're at war
with covet 19 and public private
partnerships like the historic one that
we're celebrating today
well there are major reason that last
week
i was privileged enough to witness some
of the very first
residents in our home state of new
jersey
receiving doses of our vaccines just
13 months 13 months after we started the
development process
when one of the residents at this senior
apartment
was asked how she felt after her she
after uh
she was given the shot she looked at me
and replied
safe right couldn't be i couldn't be
more proud
in our new collaboration with merck it's
going to allow us to even be
more ambitious in our goals of keeping
as many
people around the world as safe as we
possibly can
with our effective one-dose vaccine
so i'm proud extremely proud to count
ken frazier
as an active partner as we bring our
companies together
in new ways on behalf of humanity
we share one common goal above all
things
and that is advancing public health so
please join me
in welcoming ken frazier
give us the exact timing please
of these vaccines
[Applause]
double mask sanitation happening
and then given the go ahead
mr president i want to begin by thanking
you
for the steady practical and resolute
leadership
you and your administration have
provided
putting people before politics and
fostering
an environment in which private sector
manufacturing and scientific
capabilities
can work in healthy partnership with
government
to create a force multiplier in a battle
we simply must win
i'm also pleased to be here alongside my
friend and colleague
alex gorsky to talk about our historic
collaboration
the covet 19 pandemic has affected
all areas of our global community
it has created profound challenges and
hardships
especially for our most vulnerable and
disadvantaged people
and communities it has also shown a
light
on the resilience of our first
responders
scientists health care workers and those
providing
essential community services the real
heroes of this challenging moment
at merck we are proud to contribute to
the global response to the pandemic
through this collaboration with our
colleagues at johnson and johnson
and the biden administration we will
work together
to enable more timely delivery of much
needed medicines and vaccines for the
pandemic
now some observers may view this
corporate partnership
as the coming together of rivals but in
these extraordinary times
we are colleagues not competitors
the funding made available by the biden
administration
will enable us to adapt our
manufacturing facilities
for the production of covet 19 vaccines
and medicines including johnson and
johnson's vaccine
with the support of the biden
administration and specifically the dpa
we will expedite the modification of our
equipment
again i want to thank president biden
alex gorsky and his colleagues at
johnson and johnson's for their
remarkable scientific achievements
and my colleagues within mert for
helping to facilitate
this important partnership and now
it is my distinct honor to introduce the
man
who has brought the full weight of the
federal government to bear in fighting
this virus
wow president joe biden
neither of the ceos said biden was a
gift from god
remember when mike pillow referred to
trump as a gift from god i guess they
must not really think biden's that great
i don't know
well i thank you both for those words
you know you and i knew one another
when i wasn't president you weren't a
chairman right we drive back and forth
on amtrak he lived in philadelphia i was
commuting to wilmington
it's good to see you both here and thank
both of your kind words i want to thank
scientists and researchers at johnson
and johnson
for the literal heroic effort that began
when kobe
first spread and led to the safe and
effective vaccine
that are now being co-produced today
we're seeing two health companies
competitors
each with over 130 years of experience
coming together to help write a more
hopeful chapter in our battle against
covet 19.
i just had an opportunity to meet with
both of these ceos and with their senior
operating officers
and to hear about the work they're doing
together
to produce vaccines substitute and
accelerate
what they call to take it to full finish
you know what's clear is this is
historic
nearly unprecedented collaboration
during world war
ii one of the country's slogans was
we are all in this together we are all
in this together and the companies took
that slogan to heart
for example one automaker didn't have
the capacity to build enough jeeps the
competitors stepped in to help
competing airline makers teamed up and
they produced parts for each other and
gave the american pilots
as a consequence that control of the
skies
today we're seeing the same type of
collaboration
when it comes to getting this virus
under control i
said we had to treat this like a war so
i want to thank
the two companies for showing how we can
come together and defeat this virus
by putting patriotism and public health
first
and i mean that literally putting
patriotism and public health first
your companies have been working closely
with a man you both privately and the
way over
uh bragged about jeff zions jeff is in
the front row here
i want to thank you jeff and the entire
cova team you put together
for the coordination of our kova 19
response and dr
david kessler and his team at the
department of health and human services
you know when i came into office we
began working with the team of j and j
to accelerate
and add capacity to their manufacturing
production efforts
and it quickly became clear that merck
one of the world's leading vaccine
manufacturers
was in a position to be the partner we
needed in this effort
in this wartime effort i've not
hesitated to use my power under the
defense
production act to expedite critical
materials and vaccine production
such as equipment machinery and supplies
and it's not just johnson and johnson
and merck
pfizer moderna also work closely with us
to help speed up
the delivery of millions more doses the
result is that we're now
on track to have enough vaccine supply
for every american adult by the end of
may wow months earlier that is huge
and today i'm directing jeff and
my hhs team to produce another
100 million doses and purchase another
100 million dose of the johnson and
johnson vaccine i'm doing this because
in this wartime efforts we need
maximum flexibility there's always a
chance that we'll encounter unexpected
challenges
or will there'll be a new need for a
vaccine effort or vaccination effort
a lot can happen a lot can change and we
need to be
prepared and of course we need to match
the miracle of science and the skill of
manufacturing
with the massive logistical undertaking
of vaccinating over 300
million americans already we have gone
from johnson and johnson vaccine
authorization to shots in the arm
in three days i was telling the
gentleman we were at a
facility yesterday of veterans of
outreach and there were
four or there were three members of the
veterans community
getting shots one was getting of each of
the three vaccines
and the guy in the middle of veteran was
getting his and i was standing about as
far away as i am from you
and standing up and he was sitting down
and as the nurse put in his arm he went
jay and jay just one
wow there's millions of people are going
to feel that way
explosive to have be in a position that
they're
an ability to get the kind of help they
need seven weeks ago only eight percent
of the seniors
those most vulnerable to covet 19 to
receive the vaccination today
60 percent of the people over the age of
65 or older
have received at least one shot and
that's because
this is the population that represents
80 percent
of the of the kova 19 deaths we've
opened
us we've opened support and opened
excuse me and supported more than
500 community vaccination sites
that's more and and they're
administering hundreds of thousands of
shots a day
and for folks who aren't near a pharmacy
or mass vaccination center we're
deploying mobile clinics
like vans are going to places to meet
the folks where they live
we're also supplying vaccines but this
is this is all great
i think you need like the slap chop guy
to distribute the vaccine or something
cartoonish
communities and this is important
because we know we have more to do to
ensure
everyone is treated with equity and
those most impacted get the care they
deserve
on saturday we hit a record of 2.9
million vaccinations in one day in
america
and beyond the numbers of the stories
the father
says he no longer fears for his daughter
when she leaves to go to work at the
hospital
the children are now able to hug their
grandparents
the vaccines bring hope and healing in
so many ways
again a vaccinated american is the only
way to beat the pandemic
get our economy back on track and for us
to
get back our lives and our loved ones
you know
that's why the american rescue plan was
so critical
i want to thank speaker pelosi and the
house of representatives today for
passing
the bill and i will be signing into law
shortly
this bill represents a historic historic
victory for the american people
i look forward to signing it later this
week everything in the american rescue
plan addresses a real need
including investments to fund our entire
vaccination effort
more vaccines more vaccinators
and more vaccination sites millions more
americans will get tested
including home testing schools will soon
have the funding and resources to reopen
safely
on national imperative the american
rescue plan
the partnership between johnson and
johnson and merck
proves we can do big things important
things in this country
you know i'll let me conclude with this
tomorrow night
i'm going in prime time address the
american people
and talk about what we've been through
as a nation this past year
i will be covering it more importantly
i'm going to talk about what comes next
i'm going to launch the next phase of
the covet response and explain
what we will do as a government and what
we will ask of the american people
there is light at the end of this dark
tunnel in the past year i'm as curious
as you guys
cannot let our guard down now or assume
the victory is inevitable
together we're going to get through this
pandemic and usher in a healthier
and more hopeful future so there's real
reason for hope folks
there's real reason for hope i promise
you so may god bless you all
may god protect our troops and may god
ease the pain in the heart of so many
who've lost
so many people in this pandemic thank
you and
i really that we're going to do this
we're going to get it done thank you
the surplus will if we have a surplus
we're going to share it with the rest of
the world
we've already decided we're going to
work with
the outfit kovacs we've committed 4
billion dollars kovacs
get the funding for more vaccines around
the world
this is not something that can be
stopped by a fence no matter how high
you build a fence or a wall
nice so we're not going to be ultimately
safe until the world is safe
and so we're going to start off making
sure americans are taken care of first
but we're then going to try to help the
rest of the world thank you
all right there is joe biden announcing
the production and acquisition
of 100 million one-shot doses
one-dose shots one-dose vaccines
this is the jnj vaccine janssen as we
like to call it as
dr fauci refers to it uh to be a whoa um
to then be produced by merck tomorrow
night
tomorrow night joe biden will address
the nation on the next phase of kovid
almost
a year to the day now fact check me was
it not march
12th when trump did the initial
shutdowns
i'm trying it was either the 12th or the
15th or something like that
um almost a year to the day
we will be hearing from joe biden about
the next
steps the next steps on fighting code
march 13th around the 15th okay
we'll we'll see i will be with you guys
tomorrow night
okay for joe biden's national address
presumably he will already have signed
coveted relief
into law it was passed by the house
earlier passed by the senate over the
weekend all right so a lot of things are
happening
a lot of things are happening that will
do it for me today
we will see everybody tomorrow clips
podcast and then joe biden's national
address tomorrow night